depression is a state of mind that I
have had to struggle with my my entire
life more successfully I suppose in
later years than in earlier years is I
learned to find ways to manage it and to
to deal with all the things that it
entails but it's affected me quite a bit
personally I'm shooting this video in
part because viewers have been asking
that I shoot more personal videos they
actually want to get to know something
about the guy doing these these
philosophy lectures more personal stuff
and one of the things that people have
asked me about specifically is
depression
so that's that's this video that's what
this is about
I'm not going to try to talk about you
know grand scheme things like all the
causes of depression or whether the DSM
is getting it right or how do you know
if you're depressed I mean there's tons
of websites and resources out there on
that sort of thing I guess what I'm
going to do with this more is talk about
what it's been like for me personally
also in terms of my profession
philosophy the studies that I've engaged
in and what's worked for me what hasn't
worked for me some of the things that
that I had to deal with in the course of
finding out that I was depressed and
then you know afterwards what to do once
you actually know you're depressed they
died also want to take some time at the
very beginning of this to say well you
know if you're if you're actually
depressed you you have my sympathy I
know at least what it's like to some
degree everybody's depression I think is
a bit different but at least there's
some common things that we call
depression and I've gone through it for
me it hasn't it hasn't been in terms
very often of things like you know
suicidal ideation or
things like that but you know depressed
mood I remember when I was in the Army
and somebody asked me at one point
do you have suicidal thoughts because I
told my squad leader that I was I wanted
to go in and put the gloves on and get
in the ring with him and beat him up so
they they were just like hell yeah and I
said no I don't I don't have suicidal
thoughts I'd much rather you know if
something like that was going to happen
I'd rather be somebody else that gets
done in instead of me so much of much of
my activity in that way has been
directed outward but I but I have
struggled with you know the the doom and
gloom with the feeling like things are
valueless with having the sort of
negative thought dynamics that keep on
repeating themselves over and over again
with some of the things that people do
to try to to to deal with the depression
on successful you know risky behavior
drinking things like that I have a lot
of experience with that sort of thing
and I also know what it's like once you
actually do get diagnosed how how people
start to treat you differently and how
that doesn't always work out that well
for you so again if you if you are
depressed yourself you've got my
sympathy for what it's worth so I'll
just talk about what what it's like for
me so depression is something that is
tough to deal with in part because it's
tough to really adequately understand
and I don't mean understand in just a
sort of cognitive intellectual put it
down on paper definition even you know
diagnostic statistical analyses you know
differential things I'm talking more
about a practical mode of understanding
where you get your head around what it's
like for the person who's depressed what
it's like for you what depression does
to to a purse
to the relationships how it how it
functions how it actually works
something a bit more pragmatic and one
of the things that makes depression so
tough is that it intersects with it
connects up with and even to some extent
kind of parasitically involves itself
with other life issues with your
relationships with with the environment
that you're in and so it's tough to draw
border lines and say okay here's where
this is all due to depression and this
is all due to other stuff going on
everything gets kind of mixed together
and one of the big mistakes I think
people make is they say Oh depression
okay so everything it's colored with
with the color gray or blue or whatever
you want and now everything becomes part
of the depression and that's not the
case even for people who are severely
depressed but it does play a big role
and another thing that makes it kind of
tough is to a certain degree
depression is always going to be a
self-reinforcing dynamic so once you
once you're depressed
it gives you certain effects and certain
thoughts it leads to these it tends to
produce certain actions or inactions or
emissions you pay attention to some
things and not to other things and
because of that you wind up being more
depressed or your your depression gets
sort of reinforced and and consolidated
once it takes roots it's not like it has
just a single root that goes in it
spreads itself out through a lot of
different things and it I don't want to
say it takes over the person but the
person becomes shot through and through
because of the way that we are in the
world because we're acting beings
because we develop over time once you
become depressed it's easy for it to be
sort of congealed within within your
very personality so that's another thing
that that's kind of tough too
it's also difficult to determine even if
you have really great therapists and you
have access to all the information that
you need exactly what's coming from from
what source so for example I could you
know this is another thing that that's
integral to my way of viewing the world
and viewing people and all that when it
comes to nature versus nurture I always
say that's a that's a false dilemma
that's a insufficient way of looking at
things it's a mistake to actually to
pose things in terms of nature versus
nurture because there's a third thing
that always gets left out and that is
our capacity to choose to determine for
ourselves where we're going to go you
know we get dealt certain hands by
nature so for example I might be
depressed because I have a chemical
imbalance I don't know because nobody's
ever done done blood tests for that sort
of thing in part because never had very
good insurance or the kind of doctors
who actually wanted to check that sort
of thing and my depression is fairly
manageable but could be that that part
of my my depression is genetic
predisposition how that plays itself out
depends on the larger matrix of my life
and what goes on within my life and how
I over time over and over again choose
to orient myself towards the things in
my life the actions I do the
consequences of those actions the things
I don't choose to do what I pay
attention to what I don't pay attention
to all those things factored in so it's
not that nature except in very extreme
cases is wholly determinant what about
nurture what about you know how you were
raised or you know did you grow up in in
a household where other people are
depressed or did you experience a lot of
grief when you were young you know all
these sorts of things you know in my
case to you know being adopted even
though I was adopted into
a great family which would she had its
problems but on the whole was was a good
family and a loving had a place for me
never treated me as if I was anything
other than somebody who was desired to
be in their their family as if I belong
there is a kind of grief that that at
least has been you know reported about
that goes along with with being adopted
now all those things are you know the
hand that you get dealt and you get
dealt additional cards as time goes on
to write because it's not as if
everything is just they are present from
the start you you engage with other
people you learn things along the way
your environment changes your
relationships change you go through
stages of life but you always have some
degree of your capacity to make choices
I want to say anybody's like a hundred
percent responsible or even ninety
percent responsible or eighty percent
but you have a capacity to intervene
that's what we call the will even before
they coin the term the will the Greeks
had a conception of this called proi
raíces that Aristotle talks about
Epictetus talks about this this enduring
set of choices that you make over time
that that have consequences for who you
are and how you're going to manage
things and what kind of person you're
going to be and the later actions that
you're going to engage in how you're
going to feel we have some degree of
responsibility for that now figuring out
exactly where again the borderlines fall
that's very tough and I don't think that
there's a one-size-fits-all theory for
that and anybody who's pedaling one is
probably just trying to make some money
off of you or at is actually kind of
crazy themselves if they truly believe
that but that doesn't mean that there
aren't general guidelines that we can
get better and better about applying to
particulars including to our ourselves
if we're if we're reflexive and thinking
about this also doesn't mean that there
aren't people who aren't you know quite
skilled at leading you through this and
I don't I don't just mean therapists I
would
say that some spiritual directors are
good with this sort of thing I would say
that some people who study moral
philosophy and really study it in such a
way that it's not just a bunch of
theories out there but it has
application there you know some of them
are quite good at this there's some
people who don't have any specialized
training but just you know through
making the right choices ended up
developing a facility with this and I've
been fortunate enough to run into a few
in in my life and that helped me out
quite a bit so let me talk about my own
case my own situation a little bit
looking back at it I've been depressed
as long as I can remember you know not
you know like in a total funk can't do
anything catatonic kind of depression
but but I've always been melancholic
I've always had a a side that could sort
of see the negative you know kind of
disc value things there was a sense of
sadness that would come along and
sometimes I actually welcomed that and
I've also struggled with with two other
things that are that are somewhat
closely related with with depression
since I was a kid and one is is anxiety
over a bunch of different things it's
taking different different shapes at
different times some consistent things
that run through it is like you know
needing to be on time needing to to
think ahead about about what's going to
happen for a long time I had almost like
an inability to turn off the capacity to
see you know a number of moves ahead
well if I do this then this is going to
happen but that's going to happen here
and that person is going to say that you
know that that produces a lot of anxiety
and a kid I can tell you that you know I
used to feel as if
I was always being watched and judged
and not positively so I would actually
do things to like try to show I was a
normal person yeah that uh I wasn't
thinking about this sort of thing or you
know just you know kept crazy stuff when
you're a kid and a lot of kids go
through this this sort of thing another
thing I struggled with and I still
struggle with it to some degree is
management of anger and anger does go
along with anxiety and depression
because certainly for me and I know for
a lot of other people one way to try to
deal with it is simply to take the
negative feelings inside and turn them
outward with by changing them into
another feeling another aspect that of
anger that lets you do things it lets
you be active that lets you you know be
in conflict and not have to think about
how you're actually feeling or you think
about the feeling but the feeling of
anger so I've always had to deal with
those my situation is complicated a bit
by the fact that I had a number of
pretty tough blow losses as a kid why I
you know the first one would be my
grandmother died of cancer
when I was seven and you might say well
grandmother not that big of a deal but
we were we were pretty close and then
you know soon after that my grandfather
was my dad's side moved in with us he
ended up living in the basement which we
had finished and things went on for a
while and then five years later when I
was I was just about to turn 12 I was 11
my dad died and it took him a long time
actually to die and they never were able
to determine what it was that he died of
they put it down his fever of unknown
origin and this was at the Mayo Clinic
so it's not as if you know there was
some some backwoods doctor who hadn't
seen anything they they were stumped and
it took them you know
the entire summer to essentially waste
away and eventually succumb I got to see
him a few times my mom stayed up there
for the the entire summer of course once
she took him away from the Waukesha
Hospital where they just had no idea
what to do with with his case and we
visited several times my my grandparents
of my mom so I'd stayed with us and they
took care of us over that summer part of
the summer actually I spent in with my
relatives in Indiana my grandfather
grandmother aunt uncle you know all
those people when my sister went to to
stay in Chicago but it was it was a huge
blow you know my dad was only 36 it
really changed our whole way of life and
it took somebody really important for me
completely out of the picture and there
was nothing I could do you know and
people were starting to tell me well you
know you're the man of the house hearing
that didn't help out any because it led
to all sorts of conflicts between my mom
and I and also my grandfather and I then
you know there were other losses that I
had along the way but that all of my
grandparents are or go on long go on
actually I had a best friend died when I
was in college and a girlfriend died
while I was in the army a number of
other people as well in the family or
that I've been connected with so you
know when you deal with these kinds of
losses when you're when you're depressed
it's hard to see sometimes well you know
how much of it is is the actual loss and
how much it is the depression and does
the loss kind of push you know the
depression further does it
act as a catalyst for things so that
that's an issue - I had some isolation
as well because I was you know really
smart at least in the intellectual sense
United very high test scores so you know
they wanted to you know the way that
worked out in elementary school is they
just like took me out of classes and put
me in some of the other smart kids Bluff
you know in a place by ourselves and
just said here you go here some books
just do something with it or here's
here's you know some so here's a tape
recorder make a radio show about some
some English books for English class or
here's a chemistry set go go experiment
and we had like almost no supervision no
no guidance and you could tell that the
you know other kids didn't really like
the sort of thing they wanted to advance
me into seventh grade I would have
skipped sixth grade right out of fifth
grade and I did not like that idea at
all if I was going to stay in the public
schools because that would have meant
getting it was a very rough school
that's looking at going into it so then
I went to private school instead and
their huge class lines if you know most
of the kids were rich and not very smart
and there were a few of us who were
there I think basically to bring up test
scores we were we were smart but not not
rich and you felt the the class
divisions and there have been others you
know other things like that you know
being smart has not always meant I mean
individually it would mean good
relationships a with teachers unless the
teachers felt jealous or insecure but it
would tended to isolate you with with
peers so that that I think played a role
as well and again it's tough to tell
sometimes when you're feeling feeling
blue feeling bad exactly where the lines
go now I was always what you would call
high-functioning I remember actually
when I first got diagnosed I was I was
there with this this psychiatrist and he
gave me all the whole inventory they
fill in all these blanks and
so he actually got got a little worried
because the way the test was constructed
he wasn't sure whether I was mild you're
moderately depressed and that bollixed
him up so much that that should have
been a sign actually this guy's got some
problems himself with you know being
able to deal with this kind of thing but
going back to the high functioning thing
so I was I was depressed and reasonably
so because actually not too long before
that my mom had actually died she died
in 2000 when she was 54 and I was 29 so
that was that was a major blow as well
and then I got myself into a what turned
out to be just a terrible marriage
there's a whole you know story there
that I'm not going to actually go into
here and probably won't go into in other
videos either so anyway this doctor said
to me well you know what are you doing
and I was teaching at that time in in a
maximum-security prison for a college
program for your college program for
Ball State and teaching more than full
time because I was the sole breadwinner
at the time and you know writing and
publishing and all that sort of stuff
that that I do and so I said oh well
you're not depressed then cuz look
you're able to go to work and get all
this stuff done I said no I'm depressed
I'm just high functioning I'm able to
get this this sort of stuff done but I
don't feel good I you know I'm feeling
upset a lot of the time and down and
like you know nothing is going anywhere
yeah and remember to at the time I was
working the maximum security prison and
getting almost zero support from from my
my department conferences I do it you
know totally absorb the costs of those
sort of things trying to publish things
but you know that was a lot of
difficulty as well you know in part from
not having a lot of connections or not
knowing where to some things anyway all
right so I was high functioning what
were the manifestations for for being
depressed for me
I think one of the things for me is is
being too demanding and this still is a
problem for me now being way too
demanding with real concrete situations
with achievements with other people and
with with myself so I tend to to set the
bar too high and anything that's that's
not meeting that even if it's like here
I'm not I'm not adequately appreciating
that it's not down here and that there's
a huge gap from here to here I'm also
not very good with with setting where
the bar ought to be you know if I'm
doing YouTube videos every video ought
to be just brilliant and stellar and you
know if I look at them sometimes I'm not
happy with with what I would have done
with them or what I said or you know how
I was dressed or you know thinking
things like that what else
you know I one of the things that used
to be a real problem with me and thank
God it's not such a problem now is
engaging in what you'd call sort of
imaginative fantasy play about about the
self and who I was going to be down the
line and how much I'd accomplished and a
lot of that stemmed from not being happy
with where I was and who I was and the
things that that I'd done you know not
not adequately appreciating them you
know and I would sometimes like
constructive well here's where I'm going
to be at this point in time and you know
the flip side of that is where I am
right now has no value whatsoever that
was the feeling still get that sometimes
particularly now that I'm I'm sort of
off on my own I'm teaching part-time and
I'm you know shooting all these videos
and I've got a consulting company
and were you know the building phase
right now so I took a massive step down
in status and and pay and all that to do
this this sort of thing so every once in
a while I feel like you know 42 years
old
what have I actually gotten accomplished
look where I am and then there's that
tendency that to go along with that say
well this isn't any good what about over
there well five years from now I'll have
five books published and all these
articles and you know what's actually
being predicated there is all be good
I'll be okay my life will matter etc etc
if I can achieve this not it's already
good this is pretty good right here and
if I keep on doing that that's pretty
good too there's a there's a that's the
event that comes out of the depression
also you know I am some role in the
choices that I make when it comes to
that sort of thing if I know that I've
got a problem with that
then I ought to be doing my best to not
look at things that way to try to you
know try to look at the other stuff
that's out there the other evidence that
that's there um what else well you know
I can I can talk about all sorts of
things that used to be much more of a
problem some of them aren't even a
problem anymore back in the day like
engaging in all sorts of risky behavior
getting in fights you know I hung out
with the you know rough tough burn out
gang when I was in high school on for
quite a while a lot of heavy drinking
starting back in high school you know
actually I started drinking in middle
school because I knew older kids and
some of the things that we did yeah
really went over the top we're really
dumb and and why did I do that sort of
thing you know because it made me feel
alive made me feel connected to two
other people if
with an image that I wanted to cultivate
for myself and towards others and you
know I think a lot of romantic
involvements on my part went that way
too I had quite a few what we would
nowadays call hookups that I tried to
turn into a relationship and once I
would do that and the other person
sometimes would do this to in the
relationship you know you go from like
zero to a hundred in in just a few days
and set the bar way way up here oh we're
like we're perfect for each other we're
gonna we're gonna be together forever
it's you and me against the rest of the
world kind of kind of view and that's
not that's not really sustainable over
over time you know if you think it
through that that's kind of crazy talk
and even if the person is the person
you're meant to be with you generally
should get into it by increments Oh
should should get through it a little
bit easier and I can tell you when
you're depressed boy you can make some
really really stupid decisions about who
you're with and and whether they're good
for you and whether you should stay with
them whether you'll find somebody else
all these sorts of things I can say you
know and again I'm not going to say much
more about this my my first and really
bad marriage came out of being depressed
and not handling it right and looking
for you know sort of and out and people
around me recognized that and
unfortunately I was the kind of person
that they thought well we could tell him
that but it's not going to actually do
any good so they didn't and I wandered
into it and
yeah Lent all sorts of problems one of
the other things I want to talk about is
to go back to this this difficulty of
determining where the borders are one of
the biggest problems when you're
depressed is bad things are going to
happen to you because life is full of
them no matter how insulated you are
something bad is going to happen
somebody's going to die
something is going to you know go wrong
you might lose your job get a divorce
break up with your long term partner you
know it just pick whatever you're just
getting old is kind of depressing
because your body can't do the kinds of
things that you'd like it to be able to
do that it used to be able to do you
know if you're an academic and you're
really engaged with things expect to
have a lot of rejection you know I quit
collecting the rejection letters not
just for jobs but for publications a
long time ago because there were just
too many of them
and that can wear you down you know so
you put in for a position well you know
things like this have happened me I've
applied for position been told hey
you're on the shortlist for the for this
position you're our number one candidate
and then the Dean makes the funding and
no more position and then you know I
feel bad right and I feel bad in part
because there's a sense of loss or grief
or something not being fulfilled but I
always have to worry a little bit about
how much is due to the depression
there's a flip side to this too and this
has to do with other people it could
also to do with yourself depending on
what kind of person you are where you
know they'll interpret your reaction to
genuinely bad stuff you know they
mistreat you they act terribly towards
you and then if you're upset about it
well that's because you're depressed no
it's because they're a jerk and they let
you down or they actually did something
harmful and yes of course you over here
you're depressed but anybody else would
be ticked off hurt you know pick
pick whatever effect you like in those
sort of situations so that's one of the
things that's really tough about
depression I found as well now what have
I done in my case and I'm not saying
this would work for everybody but what
do I found helpful to begin with I
actually I take an antidepressant I take
wellbutrin a pretty minimal dose but I
find that it does help help me stay on
track I don't see it as a permanent
solution although you know I tried going
off it before when I wasn't doing the
sort of things that I want to be doing
in addition to it and it didn't work
the anxiety came back the depression
came back I see it as something that I'm
supposed to have so that it enables me
to to do the other things that I'm
supposed to do in order to feel better
because as soon as I stopped taking the
drug or actually as soon as it started
starts getting out of my system I'm
going to be back where I am unless I've
done some some work that's non
drug-related so the drug by itself for
me at least is just a stabilizer what
else I found helpful I've done some
therapy cognitive behavior therapy
helped to some degree not as much
perhaps as it has other people but
that's in part because for me it's
that's you know I can kind of see
through some of these these therapies
and what they're trying to do and with
what effects we're trying to produce in
that kind of lessons them other talk
therapy has helped for me as well and
for me it's not been so much about the
techniques or the strategies or the you
know the particular way of doing that
that's involved it's been about forming
a relationship with a therapist who
actually understood my particular case
fairly well and I could interact with
well I see being an academic and being
an academic and moral philosophy that
totally skews things also having had
a mentor who at the time that I was
working under him was already working on
his own you know clinical practice and
his degree and having us take these
inventories you know if I have to take
those sort of things I'm already like
thinking well this test is measuring
this this one you don't get good results
right um I would say for me that one of
the greatest resources has been my study
on philosophy and particularly of moral
philosophy you know ethics and focus on
the human person and how it is that we
make decisions how it is we figure
things out what we decide for ourselves
some of the thinkers that have been
really really useful for me have been
Aristotle epictetus st. Anselm he might
not be as useful for some others John
Cassian was not a philosopher per se
love a theologian Gabriel Marcel Cerdan
Kierkegaard I found quite helpful even
jean-paul Sartre to a certain degree
so some existentialist thinkers Maurice
blown-down
I wrote my dissertation on I found his
thought quite quite useful and also you
guy you probably wouldn't expect but
Hegel in part because Hegel who is
melancholic himself helped me see how to
look at these sort of things that are in
development that are not completely
perfected the way that you'd like them
to be I'm not saying that all these
people would be helpful for everybody
else but I know they're helpful for me
there's still part of my thinking one
other guy of William James has been
quite useful as well
maintaining contact with other people
being involved with others that's helped
out quite a bit and I can tell here's
one way that you can see that depression
is a self-reinforcing dynamic when
you're depressed you don't want to
engage with other people but when you're
depressed one of the things you need the
most is actually engaging with Ellie
some other people and being
affected with them so you don't feel so
isolated so depression tends to push you
precisely into doing the sort of stuff
that's going to make you more depressed
or keep you depressed so that's
important to do trying to find something
funny to laugh about at least once a day
I find that's important for me I need
something that's actually going to like
make me really laugh like lose control
kind of laughing like where you can't
stop laughing for at least good you know
30 seconds or so something really fine
if I do that I know it improves my mood
um finding rewarding work has been
something that's been very helpful for
me and again picking the field that I
went into and having the kind of
attitude towards it that I do that's
been really helpful and rewarding work
has to be rewarding in two ways when it
comes to depression that are really
going to help you out I don't mean
rewarding like other people are gonna
look at you and say hey you know you're
you're you're so important you're doing
a great job any of that sort of external
stuff and I don't mean necessarily
making a ton of money at it although
it's nice to have money what I mean are
two things one is that whatever it is
that you're doing is intrinsically
valuable even if nobody says good job
even if other people don't necessarily
even benefit from it so I mean getting
to study Plato for example let alone
teaching Plato putting together
resources on Plato that's intrinsically
valuable impart cos Plato's engaging
with things that are intrinsically
valuable so if you if you find that kind
of thing if you find meaningful work
like that that's going to help you out
if that work also helps out other people
in particular particularly if it helps
them out with really basic fundamental
things that matter to them that and you
can actually focus on that and keep your
mind on the fact that that's going on my
wife is always telling me for example
remember that these
videos are important and that they're
helping out a lot of people because I
attended to you know because I am
subject to this I tend to let that slip
away if you can do that if you can find
work like that to involve yourself in
even if it's not paid work you know
volunteering helping somebody else that
will help you out with with depression I
fight last thing I want to say well
actually to two things I want to say but
a lot of philosophers have been
depressed believe it or not it does not
mean that you know an intellectual life
or philosophy necessarily makes you
depressed but I think that it's kind of
good to you know be able to look at it
and say yeah okay some people have been
able to be depressed and think these
great thoughts and you know even write
books I mean John Stuart Mill is one
famous case and in part he says it
happened because he didn't have a real
childhood and I think he had a real real
complaint there William James had
depressive episodes that he had to deal
with quite often he writes about it in
very helpful ways I think Hegel himself
was was reputed to be melancholic and
yet he was a just a brilliant
philosopher who produced some some
challenging works that I've gotten a lot
out of sir and Kierkegaard another
example somebody who struggled with
depression and we could go on and on and
out of that so I don't know if that's
helpful for me it is to know that that
it's not that unusual James himself
seemed to think that if you're not you
know severely depressed but somewhat
depressed that you're actually seeing
reality more clearly than than that
other people you call these the
tenderest the tough-minded I don't know
I I tend to think that if you're
depressed you're also overlooking some
some important parts in reality as well
but I will say this if you are depressed
you're
probably picking up on some things in
your environment that are actually there
it's the trouble is exclusively focusing
on them so the one thing I want to close
with but I think is really helpful and
again I don't put this into practice as
much much as I should but I do find that
it is really helpful one of the problems
with depression is feeling like what
you've done who you are what your
prospects are they're all valueless
people don't love you
you're not lovable you never get
anything done you know you can go on and
on and on right if you're depressed you
know exactly what I'm talking about and
what I want to say is really helpful is
you've got to find others not everybody
but certain select others and let them
be the judge of that in my case I do a
lot better if I listen to my wife more
often that I do sorts of things right
and some of the other people that are
involved in my life because I actually
have accomplished quite a bit and I and
I do get quite a bit done and the things
that I've done have actually helped some
people people write me and let me know
that but I have a tendency to overlook
that and if I want to feel better it
would be really smart for me to let
others judge my own progress my own
value you know there's something to that
you know you don't want to just try to
do it all on your own
you want to have other people help you
and I think one of the ways in which
other people can help you is by calling
your attention to what you what's real
about you because you're not just your
depression
you're not just feeling blue you're not
just whatever it is that you do blowing
up at people feeling anxious withdrawing
from people that's not everything about
you and when you're depressed it's it's
easy to slip into the pattern of
thinking that that is all that you are
what you need are other people and it
only takes a few who can consistently
tell you know here's what you are
and I care about you I value I love you
because of that